calling in from Paris is Notah Begay how
are you sir I'm doing doing great rich
I'm great to be on thank you so we have
a few minutes with you here let's jump
right into it what what happened to the
Americans in the afternoon was it was it
what did they serve for lunch I guess is
my guess
whatever it is they should serve it
tomorrow because the Europeans went out
and served some humble pie in the
afternoon and it was it was a tough
session for the Americans and they just
got outplayed and they got outplayed and
then they made a lot of mistakes I think
the European one um I believe close to
30 whole excuse me and the Americans
only want about nine it was a lopsided
afternoon so I guess the question let's
let's take it one at a time the fact
that Tiger and Patrick Reed I I just
love that pairing just on paper it did
not bear out towards the end I was the
only match that they lost in the morning
and then no Tiger at all in the
afternoon is that something that Tiger
wanted well what do you think about
Tigers day Notah
well I think that captain Furyk got
caught sort of having wanting to get his
players out getting everybody out and to
try and get the rookies out to get some
get a feel for the Ryder Cup and and he
had the Cindy Shambo out and Nicholson
Andy Shambo pairing developed sort of
early in the week and so I just it was a
tough tough position to be in and you
you put these guys out and you look at
sort of who they are as players and you
hope that they can sort of elevate their
play to accommodate the situation and
that just wasn't the case and so I think
Tiger was never gonna play all five
matches I'm just simply not not able to
have that type of endurance anymore so
he had to sit out at some point I guess
Jim Furyk fought this afternoon what's
the best place to shoot him so no to be
game here on the Rich Eisen show what
does Furyk plan for the weekend best you
can tell here down to well I think that
as far as the 4-ball session goes which
will be the first session tomorrow
Saturday morning you're gonna see Dustin
Johnson and Rickie Fowler a lot again
you're gonna see Brooks kepco and Toni
FINA go out again I think he may try the
reap woods pairing one more time and
then I I think that with the success
that jordan Spieth and and Justin Thomas
had you're gonna see a really similar
lineup to what you saw today because
they had so much success but come
foursomes they need to do something they
need to switch those pairings up they
need to sort of try and figure out some
better combinations because the
Americans just didn't hit any fairways I
mean I was with the the Thomas Spieth
match against Mullen Ari and Tommy
Fleetwood and not that's just a tough
tendon the Europeans have a good tandem
in those two guys and so you know
they're pretty accurate off the tee and
they're good iron players thomas lee was
a much better putter than then Francesco
Molinari but Molinari came in with a
couple key putts today that they they're
the Americans were really never in that
match and so it's really tough to come
back in the foursomes format the
alternate shop well Matt when you get
down early Notah Begay the third here
from the Golf Channel and Noda you've
been in tiger's circle for a long time
I'm wondering if you can give voice to
somebody who's been in that circle what
it was like to watch Tiger win in
Atlanta and then show up triumphantly to
a Ryder Cup once again you know I was it
was like I look back to sort of the dark
times and that first time I I walked
into his house after the first surgery
and you know he literally couldn't get
get up from out of where he was sitting
without some assistance and and I really
thought it was a tough thing for me to
process because this was the greatest
athlete that ever swung a golf club he's
done things in my sport where I had
achieved some some nice things as well
but things that were unfathomable and
Breck records that'll never be broken
and and I
at the end was a consideration and then
to see all the work overcoming the
chipping just the the chipping lips if
you want to call him that
nobody does that and so he overcame that
and he found a way to develop a swing
that conformed with all of the
limitations that his surgeries had
provided I mean with with presented to
him with his body and his hip and his
low back and his rotation and there's
just so many things that he had to
change and you know none of us will ever
know
you know the countless hours that he
spent trying to make those adjustments
just so he could put a game together so
he could piece a game together and then
you piece a game together and you go out
and you don't know if it's gonna hold up
and you don't know if your minds gonna
hold up and can he play 15 to 20 events
and so you you saw the culmination of
all that in terms of he shot there he
shot the lower round early but he also
did that the previous week at the BMW
Championship but he and then he just
fell further further back from the lead
as the week progressed well the Tour
Championship he was able to hang in
there and there were certain parts of
the game that kept him in there and
those were all things that he'd built
what's in the last year and you know you
go back even 13 months ago him and I
were working it at the Presidents Cup he
was assistant captain and I was on the
support team for the for the American
side he didn't know if he was going to
play not 13 months ago now he's the 11th
ranked player in the world I mean it's
it's one of the greatest things I've
ever seen from a personal standpoint an
athlete achieve Noda thanks for the call
from Paris we look forward to the
continuing coverage on Golf Channel
starting at Saturday at the ripe time of
2:00 a.m. Eastern right here in the
state set the alarm clock no to thanks
for the call enjoy Paris obviously we'll
chat soon I think that's Notah Begay the
third for the Golf Channel the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience